春なんで髪の毛を明るくしたいなー。なんかこういうの使うと1日だけ金髪になれるらしいです。
(カシャカシャ)
(ぱ)
学生さんとかさ、 髪の毛を染めると怒られちゃうじゃないですか。
だから学生さんとかね、こういうのを使ってね、春休みの1日だけ金箔とかにすれば
すごい良いと思うんですよ。
................................................
ちゃら...
はい！こちらはじめしゃちょーです。皆さん春になったって事は！
いろんな場所。あの冬に出るとやっぱりこの天気がいいんで、皆さん外に行きたくなっちゃう。
外にもましたか？ 春  散歩とかお花見とかしましたか？！
僕は、してません！
とてもしたいところではあるんですけども、残念ながら僕は外が嫌いなのでできればいきたくない...
けどやっぱり何やかんややっぱり春だと移動することが多くなるんですよ。
外に出る事とかね。外に比較的まだ 出るようになったんですけども。
外に出る時皆さん何を持ちあるきますか？
そう。僕  多分脳みそおかしいレベルでものをよくなくしてしまいます。そこでちょっとすごいものを見つけまし た。
こちら！
この中に入ってるんですけどちょっと開けてみましょう。
いやこれまじネットで見つけたんですけど、見たときまじで画期的すぎて
これはまじで買った方がいいなと思いました。
きた。はいこちらマグマス？マグムス？
いわゆるキーホルダーなんですけども
これを僕がネットで見た時は...
やべぇ...と思ったわけですよ。で何がヤバイかって言いますと、簡単に言うと超強力なマグネットを搭載した。
瞬時に着脱可能なマグネットキーリングホルダー。値段がなんと5000円 です。
ふ...たけぇ。まあいわゆる『アレ』でしょ。
近未来型のキーケースといってもいいです。
例えば、ここに金属があります。ここにこれをぶん投げてみましょう。
(カーン!!)
は！
(カーン)
はいということなんですよ。
これ、(カーン)超強力磁石 らしいですよ 。多分磁力がめちゃくちゃ強いんですよ。ちょっと開けてみます。中身はいたって小さいんですよね。
もうほんとこれくらいのサイズ感。 でも磁石だからあんまり電化製品のところに近づけ
たくないんですよね。まってこれどう 使うの？
そういうことねOKx4。こう やって、
ここを...あ！いってぇ！！！！
危ね！x2死にかけたx2磁石が強力の上に死にやすい。
あ  くっつきましたはい。
こういうことですね。こっちに磁石。そしてこっちにも磁石。
こういう感じで多分ズボンとかに内側にこれを入れて外側にここを入れる 感じです。ただこれ危ねぇな一歩間違え たら死ぬな。
強力な磁石ほどひっつく時の強さが すごいんで、これでおくじゃんx2で これをこうするとでもう
待って。怖いな。頼むよ。指だけ挟まないでくれ。本当に行きます。
怖いよ
(パチン)
あ！x4ていうぐらいちょっとかなり 磁力が強い物なんですけども。これ はキーケースとして使うわけです。
やってみましょう。こういう感じかな？
こことかにこれより先に入れます。 こうやってここにこれを...
(カン)
来た！これでキーケースは完成しております。
鍵だったら僕キーケース をこうやってまとめてるんですよ。これは少し重いなって思ったんで
これを例えばこういうキーリングですね。こういうキーリングとかつけるんですよここに。そうしたら結構 離れづらくなっていう感じ
がありますね。金属リングがある車のカギとかもつくんで、そうなるとこれ だけつけたらもう
こういう大きな鍵のケースはいらない なっていう感じなんだと思います。これズボンのポケットに入れておけ
ば
こうやってくっつくんだと思います。
ホラ！すげぇ。バッチリくっつけますね。これあまりうごいても取れないと思います。動いても取れない！
あやべぇ。という感じの次世代の物らしいです。これが。この磁石
すごい！ということでこの磁石があれば、いろんな物をズボンのポケットにぶら下げて歩けると
思うんですよ。ちょっとどこ までぶら下げ受けることができるか実験してみようと思い ます。
セット
(カン)
はい。という訳でいろんな物をぶら下げていって見ましょう。
まずは 『SD カード リーダー』
パソコンを持ち歩く人は 『SD カード』が読み込めないと苦しいことが多いですからこういうのは無くしやすいんでこう
いうの普通に持ち上げるとすごい便利かなと思います。
素晴らしい
[拍手]
これならいつでも『SD カード』を読み込めますね。すごい。え...まじで取れなくね？
続いて『髭剃り』
男性の皆さん
髭、剃り忘れると困っちゃい ますよねそんな 時に行ったら髭剃りができるようにここについていると、
すごい便利じゃ ないでしょうか？つけ てみましょう。
ブーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー
おー
あ！やばい待ってやばい。
気持ちい♥
続いて『ハサミ』
『ハサミ』とかもう普通に持ち歩けたらかっこいいですよね。
危ね！ここで『ハサミ』で何かを切った後 にくるx4
(パチン)
かっけぇｗ。美容師さんとかにこれ いいと思うんですよ。こうやって髪の毛を切るじゃないですか
髪の毛をこうやって切っ て切り終わった後に「お客様完了しました」
(チーン)
待って
んぅ...
時間ください。美容師さんとか髪の毛を切り終わった後に「お客様、お待たせしましたした」
(パチン)
「ありがとうございました」
て出来るためめっちゃかっこいいと思うんでこれすごいお勧めだと思い ます。
『孫の手』
背中がかゆくなった時に皆さんかくと思います。これもいつも使えたら便利ですよね。
(パチン)
フィューーーーーーーーー↓
収納するとこれぐらいサイズなんで
かけます！
『スプレー』『スプレー』は一応金属なのでくっつくと思うんですよ。いきます！
これまじ実用的じゃね？
『銃』
ポケットから出し てる時間があったら撃たれちゃうんで、撃たられない間に敵を狙わなきゃいけない。そういう時
に
(パチン)
ビュン
待ってこれ全部で何個ぐらい付けれる んだろう。何でもつけそうな気がして きてこれめっちゃ
つく！めっちゃくっつく！
やばい。もうこれすごいつく多分。つけようと 思えば何でも
つきますよ。まぁクソだせぇけどな
てってってって
てーーてれれれーれー
てれれれーれー
てれれれーれ
てれれれー
てーててててててーてーてー
てーてーてーてー
てててて